on n'agit plus en toute impunité sur
internet à la suite d'une plainte
déposée par le président d'une
association de défense de l'enfance
les gendarmes de reims ont démantelé un
réseau de diffusion d'imagés pédophiles
parce qu'elle douce et bon jacques
cardoze c'est de lui qu'est partie toute
la sphère bernard vallat dont 46 ans
président du bouclier associations de
protection de l'enfance et passionné
d'internet il y a quelques mois ils se
connectent à des systèmes de dialogue en
direct les propositions qui lui sont
faites
l'orifice quelqu'un m'a envoyé un
message en demandant si je voulais
changer le tout en anglais si je voulais
changer des images gens n'étant pas
innocent mais j'ai répondu oui et là
j'ai récupéré une vingtaine de
photographies que plus abominables les
unes que les autres
bernard valade on porte plainte puis
sert de taupe à la section de recherches
de la gendarmerie de reims
l'opération h il est lancé les
informaticiens gendarmes traquent
pendant huit mois les internautes
pédophiles par durée
le biais de petits artifices
informatique donc nous sommes parvenus à
remonter jusqu'à jusqu'à preuve du
contraire nous avons démontré par la
qualité de cette affaire que les gens
qui voulaient se livrent à des actes
délictueux ne pourront plus le faire en
toute impunité
48 personnes ont été interpellées dans
toute la france quatre sont encore en
garde à vue et cinq autres mises en
examen pour diffusion aircelle d'image à
caractère pédophile
elles encourent des peines de un à cinq
ans de prison